oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bienvenue parole est à peine 6000 sa
madeleine dupuis alors cette semaine
vous pouvez bien imaginer je peux pas
passer à côté de cette visite historique
est attendue depuis très longtemps de la
délégation toc tonnes qui a été
rencontré le pape à rome on s'entend que
depuis 2015 avec la commission vérité
réconciliation c'est un enjeu énorme
c'est une discussion qui existe encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qui a été ravivée
par la découverte justement des
charniers où il y avait des corps de
jeunes anciens pensionnaires des fois
des tombes anonymes des fois des
histoires qui avait même été refusé
qu'ils vont être entendu parce qu'on
trouve ça tellement
mais ça se passait bien trop grohl et
avec la découverte des corps des enfants
on a commencé à avoir une réalisation de
ce que ça représente l historique des
pensionnats le rôle des églises dans ces
pensionnats le la réconciliation les
personnes qui en sont sortis tout les
survivants tous ceux pour quand même
dire que cette rencontre était attendue
et a eu un impact mais à différents
niveaux et la lecture justement de la
rencontre se fait encore assez en ce
moment et se fait à différents niveaux
pour moi c'est extrêmement difficile
c'était une semaine que je me suis quand
même beaucoup fait approché pour en
parler que ce soit dans les médias dans
les entrevues je peux même pas répondre
à la demande tellement les gens
voulaient entendre parler mais c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que c'est
pas un moment uniquement dans l'histoire
c'est un moment qui est vécu encore
aujourd'hui par des membres des
communautés autochtones un peu partout à
travers le canada mogo l'implication de
l'église catholique dans mon éducation
dans mon enfance dans les impacts
justement que eu par rapport aux
générations passées est encore présent
aujourd'hui donc pour moi c'est
extrêmement sensible et d'en parler avec
le détachement c'est quasiment
impossible
mais cependant quand je regarde les
événements quand je regarde comment les
membres des communautés réagissent
différemment je peux me reconnaîtra
tellement de niveaux et je peux voir
aussi pourquoi il ya une
dispersement tête dans l'opinion 2 est
ce que c'est une bonne chose est ce que
c'est une mauvaise chose pour beaucoup
de gens c'est une bonne chose quelque
chose qui était attendu à voir et
recevoir des excuses être reconnu pour
le moment historique pendant longtemps
on a même des gens qui disaient qu'on
avait inventé les pensionnats à un grand
plan à travers le canada est d'avoir le
pape reconnaître le chef de
l'institution catholique reconnaître que
ça a été des évènements qui sont
arrivées de présenter ses excuses et je
sais lorsque aussi je vais avoir des
problématiques parce que je trouvais
qu'il le faisait beaucoup à titre
personnel et non au nom de l'institution
sale année quand même pour beaucoup de
gens différentes manières de le vivre
donc on voit des gens qui sont qui
attendait ses excuses comme un
soulagement d'avoir
enfin on y re connu ça va certifier
c'est comme un peu à voir le santon
d'approbation d'église pour deux oui
c'est vrai ça s'est passé alors que ça
fait des décennies que les survivants
des pensionnats essaie de faire entendre
leur histoire c'est de faire croire on
passe à travers la commission justement
donc est un soulagement pour beaucoup il
y en a pour qui c'est trop tard trop peu
trop tard ça veut rien dire il y en a
pour qui ils voudront jamais recevoir
des excuses c'est jean l'institution
leurs excuses sont vides de sens alors
voulu comprendre que ces lectures de
sont très différentes et d'avoir une
délégation autochtone
il ya toujours en jeu que ça représente
toutes les communautés autochtones parce
qu'ils aient encore une certaine
généralisation des autochtones
se mobilisent on parle d'une délégation
mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui auraient
préféré que cette délégation le ne se
rendent pas ils auraient préféré que la
délégation soit le en attente de la
visite du pape qui est d'ailleurs été
promis par le pape lui-même donc c'est
de dire pourquoi nous on à se déplacer à
rome pour recevoir des excuses pour
faire des chants des danses pour prouver
encore une fois qu'on est des victimes
des bonnes victimes
go ces discussions est en train d'avoir
lieu on parle aussi de dire est ce que
la justice
s'était plié face à eux s'ils iront
jouarre étatique
toute cette discussion n'a eu lieu alors
il est d'autres discussions à travers ce
répit je puis vous dire que ça finira
pas la délégation qui vient représentent
les premières nations les inuits et les
métis et chacun amène aussi des enjeux
qui sont distincts de ces trois grands
groupes le les métis parents qui ont été
exclus justement des redevances de qui
ont été données aux survivants des
pensionnats on parle aussi même de
l'effet des écoles de jour qui ont été à
la suite des pensionnats et toute cette
discussion là commence à faire pas à
ressortir et là je rentre même pas dans
l'intention derrière la visite qui a été
choisi pourquoi été choisi pourquoi
telle personne peut-elle personnes des
personnellement moi c'est de voir
monsieur phil fontaine pied
un grand chef de la f1 l'assemblée des
premières nations mais qui aujourd'hui
quand même travail pour des institutions
que tels que des banques ou pour les
énergies a été créée des relations entre
les premières nations et les industries
des énergies fossiles les industries
c'est tout ça si je me dis mais pourquoi
est ce que lui me représente alors que
justement ils représentent des
industries c'est cool c'est quoi tout ce
mélange a donc vous voyez avoir beaucoup
de lecture à beaucoup de niveaux des
gens qui seront pas contents des gens
qui vont se demander pourquoi et des
personnes qui vont être très heureuse
parce qu'ils veulent passer à l'étape
suivante de passer à la guérison mendy
rizon c'est pas un c'est régal pour
chacun
la blessure est pas égales pour chacun
chaque personne ne peut pas sortir de
leur historique parce que chaque
témoignage qui a été fait dans la
commission vérité réconciliation ont été
de violence ou d'expérience est
totalement différente des réponses qu'on
est totalement différente face aux abus
des moments de guérison il ya des gens
qui vont revivre justement une autre
motivation du fait de cette rencontre
donc on voit une lecture très grande et
comme je disais je trouvais qu'elle pas
beaucoup je m'excuse jeudi j'aimerais
que l'église est avec l'institution
s'excuse pas c'est en se rappelant va
changer est ce que le prochain pape un
peu comme les premiers ministres qui
change un peu comme les têtes
dirigeantes qui changent et que quand
ses dirigeants elle se déplace vers
d'autres rôles les nouveaux qui arrivent
tous les recoins vaincre faut recréer
des relations donc en s'assurant de ces
l'église catholique et reconnaît ses
torts qui prend des engagements clairs
signé mais c'est cette institution et
qui va continuer et pas uniquement le
pape qui présentement siège avec vous
voyez c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement large à lire est très
difficile qui est très lourd à porter
même d'avoir à en parler de donner son
opinion amen dans les communautés aussi
des disputes des contradictions et des
personnes qui sont extrêmement
religieuse encore avec la religion
catholique
les religions chrétiennes et d'autres
qui se sont complètement détourné des
religions là pour aller vers une
spiritualité et d'autres personnes qui
n'ont jamais été touché par la religion
catholique par chance pour eux
dans les mauvais impact et qui eux ont
aussi une vision très différente donc
ces discussions même qu'au sein de nos
communautés ont lieu et il faut pas
oublier que nous autres on se trouve du
temps sous un microscope qui est celui
de la plus grande communauté la plus
grande société qui en profitent souvent
pour
apprendre mais aussi pour juger les
communautés autochtones soit dans la
réaction soit dans la leur approche
alors faut voir
ce qui va être intéressant c'est de voir
ce qui va se passer comment sa visite
vaut ce faire au canada
il faut qu'ils aient quand même des
engagements clairs il ya des artefacts
qui se trouve présentement à rome une
discussion autour de vouloir rendre les
objets dans les communautés on parle
aussi des compensations monétaires pour
les membres des communautés autochtones
qui ont pas été reconnu et le n'hésitez
pas à comprendre qu'il ya d'autres
enjeux qui vont venir par en dessous par
les côtés on parle de personnes qui vont
vouloir se faire déclarer autochtone
pour pouvoir recevoir des indemnités
parce qu'ils ont été justement là des
écoles des écoles catholiques où
vous allez voir ça va être gros un
progrès ou mais on peut panique c'est un
moment historique que c'est un gros
changement dans la discussion que sa
louve une porte mais ça l'est aussi la
porte d'une boîte de pandore et comment
les communautés autochtones vont être
supportées par le grand public par les
gouvernements par les institutions
religieuses à partir d'aujourd'hui vont
être très importantes à voir nous on ne
vit dans les dernières semaines il ya
donc d'autres déclarations que j'ai
faites par des gouvernements provinciaux
les gouvernements fédéraux et c'est
toujours à part inégal donc des bonnes
nouvelles des mauvaises mains on est
toujours un petit peu pousser tirer et
ça vient prendre une charge émotionnelle
énorme en même temps contrer ces milieux
de réconciliation ou qu'on vous même la
guérison qu'on doit passer à travers
avec l'histoire des pensées
vous imaginez donc quand je verrai en
reparler très certainement dans les
prochaines chroniques
j'espère que vous comprenez que c'est
pas une opinion unique j'espère que vous
comprenez que d'autres personnes qui
vont apporter leur grain de sel qui va
avoir déjà un compte mail à des
présomptions de pastis c'est normal on
est pour un groupe analytique donc
n'hésitez pas à partager cette chronique
et c'est pas non plus à nous envoyer des
questions et à supporter vos communautés
regardez autour de vous et à vous
renseigner justement sur l'histoire qui
était trop longtemps ignorée par les que
vous n'aviez communauté autochtone par
rapport à l'histoire des pensionnaires
leur choix personnel